tark has arrived in belfast for the
read-through in her soul there are many
photos some in actors and actresses
surviving in Belfast but the most
important one is a photo in which we can
see Christopher he view to us known as
tormund Giantsbane whose fate is now
confirmed the season 7 ending on the
devastating sight of the night king
riding the undead bazarian leading the
army of the Dead into the Great War a
few moments before the night King rode
Assyrian to the walled and blasted it
part both tormented beric Dondarrion
were atop the wall when the night king
attacked and even actor stayed a
numerous times that day highly doubt
their characters will be back in the
eighth season however with a photo of
Christopher Javie arriving in Botha's
for the read-through with other actors
the fate of tormund Giantsbane his turn
his ride the night Kings attacks so did
beric Dondarrion for all of that are
wondering how could have they survived
let me give you an answer on that
question first of all let me remind you
that instead of the entire wall only the
far eastern end of it was destroyed when
the leader of the White Walkers attacked
and breached the portion of it using the
undead dragon Azarian any waste a mere
probably saying that doorman and barrack
were on that very part of the wall at
the moment of the night Kings attack
which is correct and therefore they are
dead but you might be wrong about the
last part even though both of them were
located on East watch as they were
manning its defenses the monster only
survived not only because an actor that
purchased or moon has arrived for the
season 8 filming preparations but also
because there's some kind of a proof in
the final episode of the season 7 if you
all just sing closely would notice a few
details that are proving that terminan
barracks arrived and they're stuck in
the part of the wall that did not
collapse once the undead dragon started
melting part of the wall in which they
were standing instead of running down
the steps where we solved the other
members of the night which died tamil
america invest along the top section of
the wall then they turned into the icy
structure crumbling in front of them
while they were standing safely on a
section of the wall that did not
collapse and this is where they're
currently stuck now that we are Stern
destroyed limb explaining where they are
heading next the night king destroyed
eastwatch-by-the-sea along with
staircases embedded in the wall so they
are surely not going down I'm pretty
sure torment and miracle proceeded west
until they reach Castle black and once
they do they will reunite with Ted and
lead the remaining forces of the Nights
Watch south because there is no use of
them staying on the wall anymore all of
this might have been hinted by George RR
Martin's novels on which Game of Thrones
series is based in the novels it
specified that when the Kings and his
brethren sell to the wall to say the
Nights Watch during the Battle of Castle
black his forces landed at Eastwatch and
then proceeded west along the north side
of the wall and
they reach Castle black so if they could
do it in the novels why would not Roman
and Mary do the same in the series